. Let me go next to our caller from the 9
7 8 9 7 8. Who's this? Where you calling from?
Hello, this is Ray. Hey, Ray, what's up? Not
too much. How you doing today? Good.
Good. First of all, I do want to let you know
I love your show, I think it's awesome and
I really appreciate what you do.
I'm not really a singer, but I did write a
song for the president.
If you'd like to hear it. OK. God.
OK. Think think of the Mickey Mouse Club theme.
OK. OK.
Who is the leader, Rob? The states that we
are living and the way when a alday too. Are
you MP? Who is the guy in oversighted and
so clueless b when a lba t r u m p. Donald
Trump. What? Donald Trump? What's the point?
You're ignorant and so responsible. Who is
the guy to get reelected? The guy to get voted
out of office. Come election day. Deoine a
LTT. Are you MP?
Wow. Wow, I'm so speechless and without speech.
Awesome.
My question also is, do you seriously think
he has a second chance?
You mean do I think Trump has a shot at getting
elected reelected?
Yes, I do.
I think it's a serious shot and I think we've
we've all better make sure that we've got
a functioning election in November so we can
vote him out.
Absolutely.
All right. Oh, by the way, you, Sarah. Thank
you very much appreciated.
Excellent, excellent song. And hopefully we
don't get a copyright claim just from the
melody I thought would be horrible.
OK.
That's all the time I have today. Appreciate
everybody calling in. Sorry I couldn't get
to everyone, but someday, someday we will
take calls again.